hello sidney
it's an honor
say it ain't so nev campbell won't be
returning to woodsboro for the sixth
scream movie following a pay dispute
with the studio the canadian actress who
originated the role of sydney prescott
in the 1996 original slasher flick has
rejected the studio's salary offer
because she felt it did not equate to
the value she has brought to the
franchise over the years in an official
statement nev says sadly i won't be
making the next scream film as a woman i
have had to work extremely hard in my
career to establish my value especially
when it comes to scream i felt the offer
that was presented to me did not equate
to the value i've brought to the
franchise it's been a very difficult
decision to move on to all my screen
fans i love you you've always been so
incredibly supportive to me i'm forever
grateful to you and to what this
franchise has given me over the past 25
years
now the first scream film was a surprise
box office smash that helped revive the
horror genre and until the reboot of the
halloween franchise it was the top
grossing slasher movie of all time do
you like scary movies what's the point
they're all the same some stupid killer
stalking some big breasted girl who
can't act she's always running up the
stairs and she should be going out the
front door it's insulting earlier this
year nev entered into contract
negotiations with paramount pictures and
spyglass media about returning for the
sixth installment following the huge
success of last year's screen movie
you ready
for this
never while she did not disclose the pay
offer nev previously spoke out about
fair compensation admitting though she
did all right with scream three she did
not get a back end pay deal which allows
for a bigger payout based on a film's
success
you know there's always the promise of
back end and then of course it's it's
drowned in
publicity and costs and all the reasons
they say oh actually no we didn't make
the amount of money that we're claiming
we made in all the press
now the sixth film is set to begin
production this summer with directing
duo matt bettinelli open and tyler
gillette who helmed the previous movie
the film will see returning sequel stars
jenna ortega melissa barrera and hayden
panettiere returning for the upcoming
slasher
[Music]